Générique
...
-Le travail c'est la santé
Rien faire c'est la conserver
Les prisonniers du boulot
Font pas de vieux os
-Bienvenue dans
"Ces idées qui gouvernent
"le monde."
Nous allons parler
de la remise en cause
du travail.
La chanson d'Henri Salvador
dont nous venons de passer
le fameux refrain,
si populaire à la fin
des années 60,
a l'actualité
d'une fable de La Fontaine.
C'est dire si elle exprime
une vérité passée,
mais qui demeure contemporaine.
En témoigne la vivacité critique
à l'égard du prolongement
de l'âge de la retraite
tant le rapport au travail
a changé dans nos sociétés
de consommation et de loisirs.
Première clarification :
la dimension anthropologique
du travail recouvre
des potentialités sociales
distinctes
entre le salariat, les travailleurs
indépendants, les professions
libérales, les agriculteurs,
les ouvriers, etc.
A cela s'ajoute la modification
des conditions de travail
la dématérialisation
due au télétravail,
l'automatisation des tâches,
les nouveaux modes d'organisation
où travail et non travail
se chevauchent.
Il n'est plus aisé de définir
une identité sociale
et professionnelle du travail,
parce que la valeur
émancipatrice et progressiste
du travail fait concurrence
à un nouvel art de vivre,
plus individualisé
et qui place la vraie vie,
sans qu'on sache
ce que cette expression hédoniste
signifie et recèle,
avant le travail.
De tout cela
nous allons vous parler
avec mes invités,
que je vous présente.
Clara Gaymard,
vous êtes dirigeante d'entreprise
et cofondatrice de RAISE,
vous nous direz ce qu'est RAISE.
Alain Villemeur,
vous êtes économiste
et directeur de la chaire TDTE,
Transitions démographiques,
transitions
économiques.
Jean-Claude Mailly,
vous êtes ancien secrétaire général
de Force Ouvrière,
et Nicolas Mayer-Rossignol,
que nous avons avec nous,
et que je remercie,
en visioconférence,
qui est maire de Rouen,
président de la Métropole,
et vous êtes également
premier secrétaire délégué
du Parti Socialiste.
Alors, vous venez de voir
cette citation d'Eric Ciotti :
"Je suis las de ce bashing permanent
du travail
"et de cet éloge de la paresse
porté par l'extrême gauche."
On est en plein dans l'actualité.
Derrière la réforme des retraites,
qui a fait l'objet
d'une procédure de 49.3,
et les motions de censure
qui ont été rejetées,
la réflexion s'oriente désormais
sur le travail,
ce qu'il en est et ce qu'il sera.
Quel lien faites-vous
entre la question des retraites
et la remise en cause
du travail ?
Jean-Claude Mailly.
-La seule question, je crois,
qu'il faut se poser,
c'est pourquoi des salariés,
si l'on parle des salariés,
ne veulent pas travailler
plus longtemps.
Quelles sont les raisons qui font
qu'ils ne veulent pas travailler
plus longtemps ?
Il y a les questions
de pénibilité physique,
les questions qu'ils se sentent mal
dans leur peau,
qu'ils sont moins bien rémunérés.
Il y a des gens qui sont prêts
à travailler plus longtemps,
le problème, c'est ceux
qui sont les plus percutés
par le projet de réforme
du gouvernement,
à savoir les populations
les moins qualifiées
et aussi ce qu'on appelle
les catégories intermédiaires,
classes moyennes, quoi.
Ce sont ceux-là
qui ont des difficultés
dans leur relation au travail.
Ils expriment
de nouvelles aspirations,
différentes, et aussi,
je pense que la crise pandémique
a transformé certaines choses,
comme le développement
du télétravail,
mais le télétravail ne concerne pas
tout le monde.
Un économiste, Bruno Palier,
fait la distinction
entre les cerveaux et les servants,
les servants étant
ceux qu'on appelait les essentiels
pendant la crise sanitaire,
qui ne pouvaient pas
télétravailler :
livreurs, caissières,
et qui, en plus,
sont les moins payés,
donc ça pose un problème
à la fois de politique globale
vis-à-vis du travail
et de l'évolution
du rapport au travail.
-Clara Gaymard,
quel lien vous voyez, vous,
dans le malaise social
et la question du travail ?
-Je pense que le malaise
est beaucoup plus profond
que simplement
l'approche du travail,
c'est la question de sens,
c'est quel sens on donne à sa vie,
quelles priorités on donne à sa vie,
et c'est vrai que
tout le cheminement qu'on a eu
depuis les années 70,
avec la standardisation,
la mondialisation, le fait que
dans les grandes entreprises,
on ait fait
des fonctionnements transversaux,
dans le jargon,
on appelle ça matriciels :
à la fois donner le sentiment
que les gens étaient remplaçables,
interchangeables,
ce qu'a bien expliqué
Cynthia Fleury, et que, finalement,
la matrice était plus importante
que les personnes.
Et ce qui me semble essentiel,
aujourd'hui, on le voit, nous,
dans la vitalité des start-up,
des jeunes entreprises,
du métier qu'on fait,
nous sommes des investisseurs,
avec Gonzague de Blignières,
on a créé
une société d'investissement
qui investit dans les entreprises
en croissance,
et nous donnons 50 %
de ce que nous gagnons
à une fondation
pour aider les entrepreneurs,
donc on a la chance d'être
dans le vivier qui fourmille
et qui est créatif,
mais toutes les personnes,
hommes et femmes,
qui sont entrepreneurs,
elles cherchent à construire
du sens. C'est pour ça
qu'ils se développent énormément
sur des sujets sur la biodiversité,
el changement climatique, etc.
-Un petite question
personnelle, Clara Gaymard.
Vous avez dirigé
une très grande entreprise.
-Oui.
-Et aujourd'hui, vous êtes
dans une petite entreprise.
Est-ce que c'est par rapport
à ce que vous venez de dire
que vous avez quitté
ce grand machin pour quelque chose
de plus humain,
qui a plus de sens ?
-C'est pour plusieurs raisons.
D'abord, parce que j'avais envie
d'aider mon pays.
Il y avait beaucoup
de french bashing,
il y avait cet article de Libération
qui disait :
"Jeunes de France, barrez-vous,
l'avenir est ailleurs."
Et avec mon associé, on s'est dit :
"Nous, on a eu la chance de réussir
"grâce à la France",
d'autant plus que je suis une femme,
que j'ai eu beaucoup d'enfants
et ce pays m'a permis de travailler
et d'être mère de famille,
ce qui n'est pas vrai,
ni en Allemagne,
ni en Espagne,
dans les pays voisins.
On s'est dit : "Qu'est-ce qu'on peut
faire pour aider notre pays ?"
On a voulu accompagner
ceux qui créent des emplois,
les jeunes entrepreneurs.
On a créé une société
d'investissement
pour investir dans les entreprises.
Et le fait qu'on donne
la moitié de ce qu'on gagne
à des jeunes entrepreneurs,
ça crée ce vivier.
C'était plutôt l'idée de se dire
comment on peut participer
au fait que non seulement il y ait
de la création d'emplois,
mais d'emplois pour lesquels
les gens sont heureux de travailler.
Nous, on a démarré à deux,
aujourd'hui,
on a 90 personnes.
-Ah, vous êtes revenue.
Vous avez quitté quand ?
-Je voudrais juste dire
une chose importante,
c'est qu'on est à parité totale,
et quand on a démarré,
les gens nous ont dit :
"Qui vous allez recruter qui va
donner 50 % de ce qu'il gagne ?"
Aujourd'hui, on est 90,
on a démontré que la générosité
était un moteur économique,
et les gens viennent chez nous
justement parce que
nous sommes porteurs de sens.
J'ai quitté General Electric
en 2016.
-Alors, Nicolas Mayer-Rossignol,
vous avez entendu parler
de manque de sens du travail.
Vous qui êtes à la tête ou,
j'allais dire, en collaboration,
d'un parti important,
le Parti Socialiste,
est-ce que vous constatez
que le travail
manque de sens aujourd'hui ?
Et quel lien vous faites
entre l'agitation sociale
liée à la réforme des retraites
et la question du travail ?
*-D'abord, si vous me permettez
de corriger un point,
je ne parlerais pas d'agitation
sociale, c'est une protestation
qui, de mon point de vue,
est parfaitement légitime,
ce n'est pas une agitation.
Je referme la parenthèse.
Sur le travail,
à la question du sens,
pour moi, je dirais que,
particulièrement
depuis la crise Covid,
et on le voit aussi dans la crise
qu'on vit en ce moment
sur les retraites, il y a trois
mots-clés qui me frappent.
Il y a d'abord la question
de la soutenabilité au travail,
ce que dit notamment Dominique Méda,
mais c'est un sujet de débat qui
convoque de nombreux intellectuels.
On le voit à travers
le débat sur la pénibilité,
par exemple, et plus largement.
Comment peut-on accepter
de continuer d'exercer des métiers
qui, pour certains,
sont reconnus comme pénibles,
pour d'autres
ne le sont pas,
alors que plus personne
ne veut y aller ?
Par exemple, l'hôpital public
ou certains métiers
dans le secteur de l'enfance
ou de l'éducation.
Quand les gens ne veulent plus
y bosser,
c'est notamment parce qu'il y a
une forme d'insoutenabilité,
en particulier quand l'âge avance.
Donc, la question
de la soutenabilité au travail,
qui est un des grands sujets
que pose notre rapport au travail
aujourd'hui,
avec l'évolution, notamment,
démographique.
Deuxièmement, ce que vous avez dit
sur le sens donné au travail.
Je ne dirais pas
qu'il y a une perte de sens
mais une recherche de sens.
On le voit très bien
chez les jeunes, les manifestations
des ingénieurs de l'agro,
de Polytechnique, de Normale Sup,
et bien au-delà,
des jeunes salariés,
qui veulent trouver un engagement,
on l'a vu dans les débats
sur la loi PACTE,
sur les entreprises à missions,
à objet social étendu,
ce qu'on appelle la RSE,
et parfois, ses déviances,
mais il y a quand même
une forme de pression salariale,
qui me paraît bienvenue,
et pas qu'en France,
ça s'est globalisé, pour que,
y compris dans le secteur privé,
pour qu'on s'oriente
vers des métiers, des travaux,
du travail qui a plus de sens.
Et puis, il y a une troisième notion
que je me garderais bien de définir,
mais qui est,
d'une certaine façon,
le bonheur au travail,
l'émancipation au travail,
c'est-à-dire comment on s'épanouit
dans le travail et par le travail.
Evidemment, pour les socialistes
mais pas que,
il y a la question
du temps de travail,
mais il n'y a pas que ça,
il y a aussi, par exemple,
la représentation des salariés
dans la gouvernance de l'entreprise,
qui est aussi une forme
d'émancipation et d'épanouissement.
Il y a la question
de la valorisation des métiers,
de l'utilité sociale-écologique
des métiers.
Avec l'évolution du monde,
certains métiers
devraient être plus valorisés
qu'ils ne le sont.
Jean-Claude Mailly a parlé
des métiers dits essentiels,
est-ce que la culture,
c'est moins essentiel que le reste ?
Je crois tout à fait le contraire.
Et on voit aussi que, par rapport
à la transition écologique,
il y a des métiers,
peut-être nouveaux,
qui sont de plus en plus essentiels
et mal valorisés dans notre société.
Je ne veux pas être trop long,
mais l'insoutenabilité de métiers
et du travail,
c'est clairement un sujet
qui pour l'instant
n'est pas suffisamment travaillé,
si je puis me permettre
ce jeu de mots,
le sens et la recherche de sens
du travail, c'est pour moi
quelque chose d'intéressant,
c'est une façon de rassembler
des forces, pas que publiques,
mais publiques et privées
et citoyennes,
vers un même objectif,
comme celui
de la transition sociale-écologique,
et enfin, cette question
si difficile de bonheur
et d'émancipation par le travail.
Si difficile parce qu'elle réclame
aussi un projet politique
et elle pose la question
de la place,
notamment des entreprises,
dans notre société.
-M. Mayer-Rossignol,
notre émission n'est pas
sur les retraites
mais sur le travail.
Vous êtes un responsable
politique important.
Très brièvement,
au malaise social actuel,
quelle issue vous verriez
pour que la tension baisse ?
Mais brièvement, parce que le sujet
est le sens du travail.
-Je vais vous répondre
par deux syllabes : retrait.
Retrait de la réforme.
-Bon. Alors, puisque vous restez
sur le retrait, je vais demander
à M. Villemeur :
cette question démographique
que vous connaissez bien,
est-ce qu'elle plombe
le régime des retraites ?
Et, comment on peut faire le lien
avec la question du travail ?
-Alors effectivement,
la population française vieillit,
c'est un phénomène qui existe
depuis plus de 10 ans,
ce qui veut dire très concrètement
qu'il y a de plus en plus
de personnes de plus de 60 ans,
il y a de plus en plus de retraités.
En même temps,
de moins en moins de jeunes
arrivent sur le marché du travail.
Mais ce qui est tout à fait
bénéfique, c'est qu'il y a
de plus en plus de gens
qui travaillent.
A notre avis,
ce qu'on n'a pas dit assez,
c'est que depuis 7 à 10 ans,
il y a de plus en plus de jeunes
qui travaillent,
de plus en plus de seniors
et que tout ça est très positif.
Mais il n'en demeure pas moins
qu'effectivement,
il est évident qu'il y aura
un problème de financement
des retraites
dans les 10 prochaines années,
même si actuellement, il n'y a pas
un déficit très important,
il va de soi
qu'il y aura un déficit...
Il y a des estimations
de 10, 15 milliards
dans les 10 ans.
C'est pour ça
qu'en tant qu'économiste,
je pense qu'il fallait faire
une réforme des retraites.
-Et l'argument financier
vous paraît consolider
la nécessité d'une réforme ?
A savoir,
que la France est très endettée,
la hausse des taux d'intérêt aidant,
il y a besoin d'avoir
une cagnotte ?
D'ailleurs, ce qu'ont reproché
les syndicats.
-Il y a besoin,
dans les 10 ans qui viennent,
d'assurer le financement
des retraites.
Si on ne veut pas baisser
les retraites
dans les 10-15 ans qui viennent,
il faut,
face à cette vague démographique,
face au vieillissement
de la population,
il faut effectivement faire
une réforme des retraites.
Or, c'est pas pour ça
que je pense qu'il fallait faire
cette réforme.
On avait pris position,
du côté de la chaire
Transitions démographiques,
transitions économiques
pour une réforme des retraites,
il y a plus d'un an,
qui mette au départ
la réflexion sur le travail
et les conditions de travail,
avant de faire
cette réforme des retraites.
On avait souligné
l'importance de réfléchir
sur les conditions de travail,
l'importance de la formation
des seniors,
par exemple, qui est absolument
insuffisante en France.
Bref, on avait mis le doigt
sur l'importance d'un débat
sur le travail.
Et donc, je trouve que
de ce point de vue-là...
Les pouvoirs publics
semblent s'engager
dans une réflexion, maintenant,
sur les conditions de travail,
sur la formation,
ce qui est une excellente chose.
-M. Mailly, vous vouliez
peut-être dire quelque chose.
-Oui. Je pense pas que...
Quand on regarde
les marchés financiers,
je pense pas qu'aujourd'hui,
les principales inquiétudes
des marchés financiers, ce soit
la réforme des retraites en France.
Si on regarde la différence
du taux d'intérêt à 10 ans
entre la France et l'Allemagne,
c'est 0,15 ou 0,20 point de base.
Je suis pas inquiet
de la situation financière globale.
Je pense d'ailleurs que,
depuis le début,
les arguments utilisés
par le gouvernement
sont tous tombés à l'eau.
"C'est juste" : non, tout le monde
a prouvé que ça ne l'était pas.
"C'est pour financer
la santé ou l'école" :
ce qui va aux retraites
ne doit pas financer
la santé ou l'école.
Tous les arguments
ont été démontés.
Si, effectivement, à terme,
je ne conteste pas qu'à terme,
après, pas à 30 ans,
les prévisions à 30 ans
n'ont guère de sens,
mais si à terme, il y a
des problèmes financiers,
il faut les regarder,
mais il y a d'autres moyens
pour régler
ces problèmes financiers
que de reculer l'âge
autoritairement.
Je veux rappeler une chose
qu'on ne souligne pas assez,
on dit que dans d'autres pays,
l'âge de la retraite
est plus tardif,
mais si on présente
les choses autrement,
quel est l'âge en France
où l'on peut prendre sa retraite
à taux plein ?
C'est 67 ans.
Ne l'oublions pas.
Et si on a tous nos trimestres
et 62 ans on peut partir.
En Allemagne, c'est 65 ans.
Mais on peut partir
à partir de 63 ans
avec au moins 35 ans
de cotisation, avec une décote.
Donc voilà, les comparaisons,
c'est toujours compliqué.
-On va revenir
sur la question du travail.
M. Mayer-Rossignol,
il n'y a pas qu'Eric Ciotti,
le patron des Républicains,
pour défendre le travail.
Fabien Roussel, du Parti Communiste,
a pu dire :
"La gauche doit défendre
le travail
"et ne pas être
la gauche des allocations
"et des minima sociaux."
A quoi Sandrine Rousseau
a rétorqué :
"La valeur travail est clairement
une valeur de la droite."
Où vous situez-vous
sur la valeur travail,
M. Mayer-Rossignol ?
Par rapport
à ce clivage idéologique.
-Je sais pas si c'est
un clivage idéologique
ou une battle de punchlines,
en bon français.
Là, on est plutôt
dans ce registre, franchement.
D'abord, les cotisations,
c'est un salaire différé,
donc c'est un choix politique
de permettre à une société
et aux uns et aux autres
dans cette société
d'avoir une partie
de son salaire prélevée
pour pouvoir en profiter plus tard
ou à d'autres moments dans sa vie,
quand c'est plus difficile,
plus pénible,
pour des raisons de santé,
de vieillesse, de prévoyance, etc.
Si c'est ça un mauvais choix,
ben non, moi, je l'assume.
Evidemment, après, il y a
des questions de curseur,
quel niveau de cotisation,
bien sûr,
mais le principe d'avoir
une forme de solidarité,
il n'est pas contesté
par la gauche.
Sur la question
de la valeur travail,
il me semble
qu'il y a un faux débat.
Si on veut être un peu provocateur,
le travail en soi
n'est pas une valeur,
il peut être...
Le goût de l'effort
peut être une valeur,
mais le travail en tant que tel,
c'est un facteur,
un facteur d'émancipation,
un facteur de libération,
de l'émancipation individuelle
pour la classe ouvrière,
pour des raisons historiques,
qui est aussi une façon de valoriser
la dignité humaine par la qualité
du travail rendu, comme les agents
du service public,
les infirmiers et infirmières,
les premiers de cordée,
comme on a dit pendant la pandémie.
La vraie question qui est derrière,
c'est pas, à mon avis,
les pour ou contre le travail,
la France qui se lève tôt
et les autres.
Ca me paraît très manichéen
comme débat. En revanche, je crois,
et c'est ce que revendiquent
la gauche et les socialistes,
c'est de quelle façon notre société
dans le projet politique
qu'elle porte,
quand je dis notre société, c'est
pas uniquement la société française,
plutôt la société européenne,
de quelle façon nous valorisons
ce qui fait du sens, l'utilité,
j'aime bien cette expression,
l'utilité sociale écologique
des métiers
et du travail qui est derrière.
-Monsieur Mayer-Rossignol,
je voudrais quand même
que vous précisiez votre pensée,
au niveau d'un diagnostic politique.
Qu'est-ce que vous pensez
de ceux qui disent
que les milieux
ouvriers et populaires
se sont sentis trahis
par une partie
de l'idéologie de gauche
sur la fin du travail
et, abandonnés par la gauche,
sont allés rejoindre
l'extrême droite ?
Est-ce que c'est
quelque chose qui existe ?
Et en plus, ça devrait vous parler,
parce que vous avez aussi,
j'allais dire, une carrière
d'ingénieur de très haut niveau.
Est-ce que vous constatez,
vous faites ce diagnostic-là ?
-Ce que l'on constate,
moi, je suis maire de Rouen,
Rouen, c'est une ville
populaire, industrielle,
portuaire, comme une bonne partie
du nord-ouest de la France,
comme la Somme. Je rappelle
toujours qu'Hénin-Beaumont,
qui est connu
malheureusement aujourd'hui
pour être un des bastions
du Rassemblement national,
c'est juste à côté
de Noyelles-Godault,
qui est la patrie, le village natal
de Maurice Thorez, de la CGT.
Donc, effectivement, dans notamment
cette partie de la France,
qu'est-ce qu'on voit ?
On voit qu'il y a eu
une forme, comment dire,
de désenchantement, de désillusion,
de violence, de colère,
effectivement, d'ouvriers,
de catégories dites populaires.
Je le vois très bien
à Rouen. Qui ont eu le sentiment
d'abord d'avoir été abandonnés
dans la mondialisation. Chez moi,
c'est la raffinerie Petroplus
qui ferme pour aller
en ouvrir ailleurs.
C'est la désindustrialisation.
Et, pour reprendre
le mot de Bruno Latour,
d'être des migrants de l'intérieur.
Le pays les abandonne
de l'intérieur.
Là où ils habitent,
il y a plus de maternité,
on peut plus accoucher
près de chez soi.
Il y a plus de Poste, de services
publics, de trains. Voilà.
Donc, oui, il y a
une forme de sentiment d'abandon,
à la fois européen et national,
l'Europe devenant un problème
plus qu'une solution, etc., etc.
Et c'est vrai,
je n'ai rien à cacher là-dessus,
on a tous notre part
de responsabilité à gauche
et notamment les socialistes,
sur retravailler et reproposer
une offre réellement
populaire sur le pouvoir
de vivre en réalité,
sur la protection
des catégories sociales qui vivent
et qui veulent vivre
dignement de leur travail.
De ce point de vue, c'est vrai,
notamment dans les années 90-2000,
la gauche a pu se perdre un peu
et singulièrement
les socialistes. Ceci dit,
on en est revenus largement
et aujourd'hui,
dans l'offre politique
à gauche en général
et socialiste en particulier,
vous trouvez,
sur la question sociale écologique,
sur le bouclier social écologique,
sur les nouveaux services publics
dans les territoires
dits ruraux ou périphériques,
des propositions concrètes
qui vont dans ce sens.
C'est un travail
de très longue haleine
et ça va prendre du temps,
bien entendu.
C'est un enjeu majeur,
le pays est clivé là-dessus.
Il est clivé au niveau européen.
-Clara Gaymard,
sur cette utopie de la fin
du travail,
c'est quelque chose qu'on constate
en France et aussi à l'étranger,
parce qu'avec votre carrière
de dirigeante, vous avez pu côtoyer
l'étranger. Vous avez rappelé
vous-même que vous avez
un lien avec l'étranger.
-Alors,
j'ai un lien avec l'étranger,
non, j'ai eu
une carrière internationale
qui m'a permis
de voyager et de travailler
avec beaucoup
de nationalités différentes.
On parle beaucoup
du désenchantement,
du refus du travail.
En fait, je pense que le sujet est
très différent de ce qu'on dit,
parce que, quand on regarde,
on cite beaucoup
les jeunes de l'Agro
qui ont pas voulu
prendre de rang de classement
et ne pas rentrer
dans des grands groupes
internationaux, quand ils disent,
et en caricaturant,
on imagine qu'ils veulent aller
sur le plateau du Larzac élever
des chèvres, il y a pas de métier
plus fatigant que d'être berger,
c'est 70h par semaine.
C'est pas les 35h.
Au fond, ce qu'il y a
dans la jeunesse et on voit aussi
que beaucoup de jeunes ne veulent
plus être salariés, ils veulent
être soit entrepreneurs
soit intermittents du spectacle
soit sur des métiers
où ils sont libres
de leurs choix, de ce pour quoi
et pour qui ils veulent travailler.
Il y a une contestation du salariat,
tel qu'on l'a conçu
et construit en France,
parce qu'on a fait du salariat
l'espèce de modèle clé,
c'est grâce à ça
qu'on obtient un prêt,
qu'on peut avoir une place
dans la société.
Et on voit aujourd'hui émerger
de nouvelles formes de travail
qui correspondent
à leurs aspirations.
Vous avez parlé
tout à l'heure du bonheur
ou de l'accomplissement.
Aujourd'hui, les jeunes,
ils veulent, ils ont beaucoup de mal
à accepter de travailler
pour quelque chose
dont ils ont le sentiment que ça va
abîmer encore plus la planète,
abîmer encore plus la biodiversité.
Et ils cherchent, au-delà du sens
personnel. Ce qui me frappe
dans la jeunesse d'aujourd'hui,
quand je parle de la jeunesse,
ça touche en fait
toutes les générations.
On voit bien l'émergence
des marchés bios, etc.,
les gens qui veulent manger bien,
qui veulent repenser leur façon
de vivre, moins consommer,
consommer français,
consommer plus intelligemment,
c'est une remise en cause d'une
société qui nous a un peu abêtis,
une société de consommation
tous azimuts, toujours plus,
avec l'idée que c'est pas
en ayant les placards pleins
qu'on est plus heureux, mais
c'est en accomplissant un travail
qui a du sens et qui est bien payé.
Et c'est tout le sujet
de notre société.
C'est qu'elle ne sait pas
aujourd'hui payer
au juste prix ceux qui apportent,
et Monsieur Mailly l'a
très bien dit,
apportent une vraie force vive,
nécessaire au pays.
On peut parler des agriculteurs,
on a parlé des infirmières.
Et je suis d'accord avec vous
que ce serait intéressant
d'avoir un sujet sur
c'est quoi, le travail, c'est quoi,
la contribution à la société,
on est tous pareils.
On est très différents,
mais on a envie de réussir
et de partager la réussite.
On est tous,
on a envie de transmettre à
nos enfants, à ceux qu'on aime, etc.
Et donc, d'arrêter de penser
qu'il n'y a que le salariat
et qu'il y a
d'autres formes d'expression
du travail, c'est exactement
la révolution
qui est en train de se produire.
-Merci. Alors, Alain Villemeur,
il y a deux cultures
sur le travail ?
Entre les générations ?
-Oui.
Mais je voudrais revenir
sur effectivement le travail
et le fait que les Français
travaillent de plus en plus.
Il faut quand même pas l'oublier,
c'est-à-dire que depuis donc 10 ans,
en gros, il y a 500 000 jeunes
de 20 à 30 ans qui travaillent,
en plus qu'il y a 10 ans.
Il y a 1,3 million de seniors
qui travaillent.
Et ça contribue à la réduction
du chômage. On a quand même été
depuis les années 80, 90
dans une culture finalement
de la fatalité du chômage.
Et le chômage est descendu
de 10 % à environ 7 %.
Donc je crois, il y a eu
tout un débat sur le travail
depuis deux mois sur une étude
de l'IFOP
et de la Fondation Jean Jaurès,
qui prétendait qu'il y aurait
une épidémie de flemme. Les Français
seraient-ils devenus flemmards ?
Je crois que la réalité
s'inscrit en faux.
Il n'y a pas
de flemmards, il n'y a pas
de flemme chez les Français.
Au contraire, ils plébiscitent
le travail depuis 10 ans.
Alors, maintenant, je crois
que le travail, surtout
au travers des jeunes générations,
est en train d'évoluer.
Ils ont de nouvelles exigences,
ce qui a été rappelé.
Ils veulent plus de sens au travail,
que ce soit conciliable
avec les conditions de vie
sociale, familiale,
et je crois que
c'est le défi qui est devant nous.
Et ça me semble justifié.
-Vous venez de voir ce que dit
Jean-Pierre Le Goff :
"La société de consommation
"et de loisirs a bouleversé
le rapport au travail."
Monsieur Mailly,
l'importance du temps libre
comme l'épanouissement personnel
contribuent
à établir une nouvelle hiérarchie
des activités
sociales. A votre avis, est-ce que
cette nouvelle hiérarchie,
elle est perçue de la même manière
par l'ensemble du monde du travail ?
-Non. Enfin, écoutez, moi...
C'est Sandrine Rousseau qui a
ressorti le droit à la paresse. Bon.
Je pense que c'était une forme de
provocation, parce que ressortir...
Je rappelle
que le droit à la paresse,
formule de Paul Lafargue,
c'était au moment, fin du 19e,
où les syndicats réclamaient
les 3x8,
8h de travail, 8h de loisirs,
8h de repos. On en est loin.
Non, non,
le travail est une activité
importante pour l'individu,
quel qu'il soit. Après, il faut
qu'il puisse y prendre
un plaisir d'une certaine manière,
qu'il se sente utile,
qu'il s'émancipe. C'est ça
qui est important. Après,
qu'il y ait... Rappelez-vous,
Keynes expliquait qu'on
travaillerait tous 30h, etc.,
et de moins en moins.
Compte tenu des évolutions, bon,
ce n'est pas le cas aujourd'hui.
Mais on a quand même globalement
une durée du travail, partout,
pas qu'en France, qui a diminué.
Permis par les gains
de productivité.
Ce qui permet
d'avoir plus de temps libre.
Ce qui change beaucoup en ce moment,
c'est qu'effectivement,
si on prend un seul exemple,
c'est celui du télétravail,
avec le télétravail qui s'est
fortement développé, il y a
un repositionnement vie publique,
vie privée, etc. Et ça évolue.
En général, dans les entreprises,
c'est 1, 2, 3 jours de télétravail
qui sont accordés.
Ca dépend des entreprises.
Et dernier point
qui m'apparaît également important,
oui, il y a
chez une partie des plus jeunes
recherche pas de salariat,
ils veulent être freelances,
mais le problème, c'est être
freelance, mais avoir accès
à une protection sociale,
être payé correctement.
Quand vous êtes salarié, vous avez
ce qu'on appelle dans le Code
du travail la subordination
juridique, mais beaucoup de jeunes
qui travaillent pour des plateformes
sont en subordination économique,
qui n'ont pas droit à une protection
sociale. Il faut travailler ça.
Cette quête d'autonomie,
y compris pour les salariés.
Beaucoup de salariés considèrent,
Clara Gaymard l'expliquait,
les nouveaux modes de gestion,
de management
dans les entreprises,
voudraient avoir plus d'autonomie
dans leur travail.
C'est une demande
aussi chez les salariés.
-Monsieur Villemeur, il y a une
question qu'on pourrait évoquer
avec l'informatisation des tâches.
Les nouvelles pratiques managériales
comme l'informatisation des tâches
sont remises en cause.
Au cours d'une émission ici,
l'économiste
Daniel Cohen a démonté
en quelque sorte
l'informatisation
des tâches en disant
que ça portait atteinte
aux relations sociales.
Vous êtes d'accord avec ça ?
Je serais plus partagé.
Si vous voulez, l'informatisation,
c'est quand même... ça engendre
des bénéfices exceptionnels.
On en bénéficie tous sur le plan
de la communication, etc.
Ca engendre
pour les économistes aussi
un effet de polarisation
du marché du travail.
Vous avez de plus en plus
de gens qualifiés
qui sont demandés
par les entreprises
et vous avez aussi de plus en plus
de gens peu qualifiés qui sont
également demandés. Donc ça,
ça pose un redoutable problème.
C'est que la classe moyenne,
en gros, les compétences moyennes,
sont en train de diminuer
et ça provoque un ressentiment,
je pense, important
dans ces catégories.
Donc, au-delà du problème
effectivement de l'autonomie
grâce à l'informatisation, il faut
prendre en compte cette dimension
de l'informatisation,
des nouvelles technologies,
qui modifient complètement
les relations de travail,
qui modifient les catégories qui
en profitent, les plus qualifiées,
celles qui en souffrent,
les moins qualifiées.
-Clara Gaymard, sur ce point.
-Je voudrais réagir. Il faut
se méfier des calculs
un peu définitifs et simplistes.
Il y a quelques années avec
l'émergence de la digitalisation,
on disait que ça allait supprimer
300 000
ou 500 000 emplois en France
dans les banques, etc.,
et que le chômage
exploserait. C'est le contraire qui
se produit. On n'a jamais eu autant
d'emplois disponibles
aujourd'hui en France.
-Mais on parle
de la qualité de la relation
sociale, on n'est pas en nombre.
-Je voulais dire
qu'on avait ce "statement"
si je puis dire, cette affirmation
que la digitalisation allait
créer le chômage
et maintenant,
on a cette affirmation
que la digitalisation allait...
Bien sûr, ça change
la façon dont on travaille,
mais c'est toujours
la même chose.
En même temps, ça facilite
considérablement la tâche.
Ca permet d'ailleurs le télétravail,
ça permet aux gens, comme l'a dit
Monsieur Mailly,
nous, dans notre entreprise, on a
2 jours de télétravail
dans l'entreprise,
c'est très apprécié des jeunes,
je peux vous le dire,
et pas seulement.
Ca donne une... ça offre
des potentialités incroyables.
Et surtout, ce qu'il faut bien
voir, c'est qu'on est loin
de l'informatisation,
maintenant,
on est dans la deep tech,
on est dans la technologie
qui est rapportée
à l'industrie.
Je veux juste donner un exemple.
Nous, on accompagne des start-ups,
je pourrais en décrire beaucoup,
mais grâce à l'image satellite,
grâce aux drones et grâce
à l'intelligence artificielle,
aujourd'hui, on arrive
à mesurer et à quantifier
quand on replante des sols
dans les endroits miniers,
sur les bords des routes, etc.,
et donc recalculer la reforestation,
la biodiversité, etc.
Ca, c'est des trucs
qui coûtent pas cher,
alors qu'avant,
ça demandait une armée
de gens, ils devaient
semer eux-mêmes, maintenant,
on sème avec des drones.
C'est pas simplement
être derrière un ordinateur,
ça touche toute l'industrie.
Aujourd'hui, quand on arrive
à faire des jumeaux numériques
dans les entreprises, qui permettent
de savoir où se trouve tel tuyau,
comment il faut le changer,
le réparer, etc.,
ça fait des économies
de maintenance,
de complexité, etc., énormes.
La technologie,
elle apporte évidemment
un bienfait qui fait que
on peut faire moins
de tâches répétitives.
Maintenant, après, tout est toujours
dans la façon
dont on gouverne l'entreprise,
quelle responsabilité
on a vis-à-vis de ses salariés.
Donner du sens à l'entreprise,
c'est aussi la façon dont on célèbre
les réussites,
dont on partage la réussite,
dont on partage la valeur,
dans la manière
dont on reconnaît l'importance
et justement l'irremplaçabilité
de chaque individu, parce que
la fonction est interchangeable,
mais chaque individu va l'exercer
d'une façon différente.
C'est donc ce retour
à la place essentielle
de la personne dans l'entreprise.
-Monsieur Mayer-Rossignol,
vous pourrez peut-être dire
un mot
sur l'informatisation du travail,
mais je voudrais vous faire réagir
sur une enquête
de l'Institut Montaigne
concernant la satisfaction
au travail, une récente enquête.
Les résultats sont
plutôt optimistes,
mais dès lors que cela concerne
les salaires en bas de l'échelle
ou de moindres qualifications,
ça n'est pas le cas.
Est-ce que vous craignez
qu'à ce niveau,
c'est-à-dire là où il y a
l'acmé en quelque sorte
de la contestation sociale,
on aille
vers un travail à deux vitesses,
on classe les sous-qualifiés
et les surqualifiés ?
Est-ce qu'on va vers ça aujourd'hui
avec une responsabilité
de l'informatisation,
si je puis dire, comme accès
plus facile au travail ?
-Oui, c'est intéressant,
votre question.
Je voudrais essayer de faire
un lien entre cette étude
de l'Institut Montaigne et le petit
échange qu'il y a eu précédemment
sur le numérique et l'évolution
au moins de certains types
de métiers et du travail
dans plutôt les fonctions tertiaires
et les créations de valeur notamment
liées aux gains de productivité
et plus largement à l'informatique,
aux technologies de l'information
et de la communication.
En fait, sans être trop négatif,
ce qu'on constate sur le terrain
et en particulier sur des villes
comme celle que j'ai l'honneur
d'administrer, comme Rouen,
c'est que vous avez
une forme d'accroissement
des inégalités symboliques
du travail. Je m'explique.
Vous avez d'un côté
ce qui a été dit tout à l'heure
des métiers tertiarisés,
de plus en plus numérisés,
mondialisés, bien payés,
moins pénibles, en tout cas sur les
pénibilités classiques, physiques,
parce qu'il y a d'autres sujets,
le burn-out, la laisse électronique,
je passe.
Plutôt bien valorisés
dans notre société. Bon.
Et puis, de l'autre côté...
Avec du télétravail,
donc avec des évolutions
plutôt perçues positivement.
Et de l'autre côté, c'est pour ça
que je parle d'une forme d'étirement
et d'accroissement des inégalités
et symboliquement
avec une humiliation plus forte,
de l'autre côté,
vous avez toujours les gars
qui bossent dans les abattoirs,
les infirmières
qui doivent porter des corps
à 3h du matin aux urgences,
vous avez toujours en fait
des réalités qu'on veut plus
ou moins voir, que parfois
on veut toujours pas bien voir.
Je pense aux questions de
pénibilité liées à la santé mentale
dans les hôpitaux psychiatriques par
exemple, qui sont encore des sujets
tabous avec des formes de travail
très mal valorisées, voire taboues.
On pourrait parler des prisons.
Vous voyez ce que je veux dire.
L'ensemble du corps social
et des différents types de travail,
de métiers associés, s'étire
en termes de possibilités,
de potentialités,
avec d'un côté des potentialités
permises par la technique,
par la technologie, par la science
et notamment le numérique
qui augmentent
et qui sont même fascinantes,
parfois grisantes,
et de l'autre côté,
une forme d'humiliation
et de sous-valorisation.
Et ça, c'est un vrai défi
pour les pouvoirs publics
et les entreprises aussi,
parce que ça veut dire
avoir une action
beaucoup plus volontariste
en lien avec les corps
intermédiaires, en particulier
avec les forces syndicales,
pour mieux protéger et valoriser
les premiers de corvée et finalement
les oubliés de ce monde d'après.
Parce qu'ils existent toujours.
Souvent on dit, il n'y a
plus de classe ouvrière, mais il y a
une classe ouvrière, peut-être
plus morcelée, fragmentée,
moins visible, moins soudée,
mais elle existe.
On a toujours besoin
de déplacer des colis. Maintenant,
je vais vous choquer peut-être,
mais c'est peut-être des migrants
ubérisés sans condition
de sécurité sociale.
Est-ce mieux ? C'est bien pire.
Est-ce qu'on se cache les yeux
et on ne regarde pas
ces sujets en face,
ou est-ce qu'au contraire,
on les affronte ?
Il faut à la fois tenir compte,
et c'est plutôt positif,
des évolutions liées à la technique
sur des métiers qui nous permettent
de penser fortement les attentes
et de répondre aux attentes
de la jeunesse, sur le sens
et la qualité du travail,
sur les nouvelles porosités entre
monde professionnel et personnel,
mais il faut aussi,
c'est le rôle de la gauche,
penser la protection
et la valorisation de celles et ceux
sans qui notre société
ne fonctionne pas.
-Merci. Jean-Claude Mailly,
je vous donnerai la parole,
Clara Gaymard,
on est là sur une question
de fond. Qu'en pensez-vous ?
-Oui, d'abord, je pense qu'il n'est
pas question de dire, il faut
arrêter l'informatisation
ou les nouvelles technologies.
Il faut regarder
comment les choses sont gérées,
s'il y a des problèmes
d'éthique, etc.
Des métiers très pénibles ont
disparu grâce à la robotisation.
Vous visitez une chaîne dans
l'automobile aujourd'hui,
vous voyez finalement peu de gens
sur la chaîne. Ca, c'est permis
par les gains de productivité.
C'est vrai que ça peut générer
une plus forte individualisation
des relations sociales.
Quand vous êtes en télétravail,
vous êtes chez vous.
Mais les entreprises
l'ont bien compris,
les salariés le demandent aussi,
un moment de collectif.
C'est indispensable.
Par rapport à ce que disait
Nicolas Mayer-Rossignol,
ça, c'est un problème de fond,
la manière
dont on reconnaît,
en France comme ailleurs,
c'est pas spécifiquement français,
les métiers dits essentiels,
invisibles, ceux qu'on applaudissait
pendant la pandémie.
Dans les années 60,
certains économistes,
américains notamment, ont considéré
que ces métiers de service,
partant en général
d'une étude des métiers artistiques,
il y a eu mauvaise extension après,
considéraient que
c'était des métiers improductifs.
Etant des métiers improductifs,
les autres
devaient les rémunérer.
Donc on n'a pas rémunéré
correctement ces métiers
depuis longtemps.
C'est encore vrai en France. Quand
le président de la République dit :
il faudra qu'on travaille
sur les négociations de salaire
au niveau des branches, il y a
encore des branches inférieures
au SMIC, je me souviens avoir
porté ce dossier en 2008.
Vous voyez. On est en 2023.
Et on avait à l'époque
obtenu une loi,
le ministre du Travail était
Xavier Bertrand à l'époque.
Cette loi qui a été votée
n'est jamais sortie
faute des décrets d'application.
Ca veut dire qu'on n'a
toujours pas réglé ce problème.
C'est un exemple parmi d'autres.
Ce sont des gens qui, eux,
ne peuvent pas télétravailler,
qui ont des horaires,
des difficultés dans leurs métiers
et qui en plus sont mal payés.
Ca fait partie
des urgences.
Et dernier point, je suis d'accord
avec ce que vous avez dit.
Les catégories en emplois
dans tous les cas, c'est pas
ceux qui sont les mieux formés,
c'est pas ces catégories difficiles,
ces métiers existeront encore, c'est
entre les deux.
-Jean-Claude Mailly,
un mot sur les syndicats. Qui se
syndique le plus ? Ces catégories
qui sont un peu en bas,
si je puis dire,
de l'échelle
ou ceux qui sont plus avancés ?
-Je vais répondre différemment
si vous le permettez.
-Sans jugement de morale de ma part.
Personne ne juge.
-Là où la syndicalisation
est beaucoup plus difficile,
c'est par exemple dans le monde
des start-ups ou chez les GAFA.
Là, c'est une syndicalisation
beaucoup plus difficile.
Ce sont des populations plus jeunes,
qui en général
essaient de s'en sortir
tout seuls. S'il y a un problème,
ils regardent sur Internet,
ils savent lire
une convention collective.
Et donc là, ce sont des milieux
qui sont à conquérir
pour le syndicalisme.
-Il n'y a pas un aggiornamento
à faire au niveau des syndicats
pour tenir compte
de ces évolutions ?
-Alors, vous savez,
comme je le dis souvent,
les organisations syndicales,
ce sont des exercices
démocratiques permanents.
C'est un paquebot,
vous le faites pas virer comme ça,
mais c'est de plus en plus
pris en considération
par la plupart des organisations.
-Clara Gaymard.
-Je voulais réagir
à ce qu'a dit
tout à l'heure le maire de Rouen.
Parce que c'est tout à fait juste
le diagnostic qui est posé
sur le fait que les rémunérations,
les métiers qui sont essentiels
et qui sont les seuls qui resteront.
Il faut pas se tromper.
La digitalisation, je sais pas si
vous avez entendu parler de ChatGPT,
mais ça permet de remplacer pas mal
de gens qui font du marketing,
qui font de la communication, etc.
Donc les vrais métiers
qui resteront toujours,
c'est ceux
qui vont planter les patates,
ceux qui vont soigner les gens,
ceux qui vont
porter les colis, ceux qui vont
faire marcher les trains, etc.
C'est des métiers réels, mais ce que
je voulais simplement dire et que
je trouve extrêmement intéressant,
c'est que vous avez
toute une génération de jeunes
qui font partie a priori
de l'élite, parce qu'ils ont fait
les grandes écoles, qui vont dans
ces métiers aujourd'hui, qui font
de la restauration, qui ouvrent
des usines pour fabriquer
des vêtements faits en France,
de la bière faite
en France, pour fabriquer
des t-shirts faits en France, etc.
Et qui reviennent
vers la petite industrie,
ce qui est permis
justement par la technologie
et qui se réapproprient ces métiers
et y mettent du savoir-faire
qui est du savoir-faire
lié à leurs études
et à leurs compétences
à la fois commerciales,
internationales, ils vont tout
de suite à l'international, etc.
Et donc, l'espoir que je vois, c'est
que ces métiers soient revalorisés
grâce au fait qu'aujourd'hui,
vous avez dans une classe
d'âge de jeunes qui sont a priori
ceux qui vont bâtir
la France de demain,
ils s'intéressent à ces métiers,
parce que c'est des métiers
qui les enracinent,
qui leur donnent du sens et qui,
parce qu'on le dit pas assez,
est une réponse à l'enjeu climatique
qui est l'obsession de la jeunesse
et qui devrait être
notre obsession à tous.
Quand on parle de la valeur travail,
on devrait la revisiter
sur la question... Le GIEC
nous le répète tous les jours,
nous devons repenser notre système
économique, notre système productif
en fonction
de ce 1,5 % ou 2 % climatique.
Ce que font les jeunes.
-Merci.
Allain Villemeur.
-Oui, les pouvoirs publics vont
lancer le débat sur les conditions
de travail et sur la formation.
Je crois qu'il faut qu'ils le
lancent aussi sur les rémunérations.
Je rejoins
ce que disait Jean-Claude Mailly.
Il y a en France
des métiers essentiels
qui sont mal rémunérés
et qui sont mal rémunérés
par rapport
aux autres pays européens.
Quand vous comparez
les rémunérations
des enseignants et des soignants,
ils sont beaucoup
moins bien payés
que dans les autres pays européens,
qu'en Allemagne.
Un seul chiffre,
les enseignants, en débutant,
sont payés 40 % de moins
qu'en Allemagne, par exemple.
Bon. Les soignants,
c'est également le cas.
Et d'où, je crois, les vraies
difficultés de recrutement
qui existent actuellement
et qui peuvent engendrer des
situations tout à fait dramatiques
au niveau de l'enseignement
et des hôpitaux, des EHPAD, etc.
-Concernant le salariat aujourd'hui,
qui représente quand même une part
importante de l'éventail du travail,
l'un des grands
reproches qui est fait,
ça vise le rapport hiérarchique
qui est de plus en plus contesté.
Est-ce qu'il y a une alternative
à l'autorité, Clara Gaymard ?
-C'est pas
la question de l'autorité,
mais l'autorité qui est une autorité
hiérarchique et pas de compétences.
Aujourd'hui, vous avez des jeunes
qui sont, sur certains sujets,
bien plus compétents
que leurs supérieurs,
et la plus grande qualité
d'un dirigeant aujourd'hui,
c'est l'humilité et d'accepter
qu'il ne sait pas tout
et qu'il ne peut pas tout.
La compétence du dirigeant, ce n'est
pas le savoir, c'est de laisser
ceux qui savent
exercer leurs compétences
et avoir des responsabilités
et les respecter.
C'est un changement de paradigme
dans le fonctionnement
de l'autorité.
-Votre avis, Alain Villemeur ?
-Je partage complètement cet avis.
Nous avons en France
dans les entreprises
une culture trop hiérarchisée.
Il faut revoir le fonctionnement
de ces entreprises et les rendre
plus horizontales, plus apprenantes.
C'est ce qui se passe
dans beaucoup de pays européens.
Là, il y a un défi
pour les entreprises
et le management.
-Jean-Claude Mailly ?
-Oui, je suis d'accord également
avec ce qu'a dit Clara Gaymard.
Un bon dirigeant,
c'est quelqu'un qui est reconnu,
son autorité est reconnue,
et qui sait s'entourer.
-Oui, alors, Nicolas
Mayer-Rossignol,
sur cette question de l'autorité,
est-ce qu'il y a une alternative,
qu'est-ce qu'il faut
changer à ce niveau-là
ou pas changer d'ailleurs ?
-Je fais une suggestion,
mais qui n'est pas si originale.
C'est de renforcer
le rôle et la place
que peuvent occuper les salariés
dans la gouvernance de l'entreprise.
Ca a évolué.
Je veux pas être manichéen.
Mais reconnaissons que, par rapport
à d'autres pays en Europe,
par rapport
à d'autres modèles de sociétés,
la France est peut-être pas
le plus en avance là-dessus
à travers leurs représentants,
les syndicats,
à travers peut-être d'autres formes,
dans les pactes de gouvernance
des entreprises.
En tout cas, il me semble
qu'il y a quelque chose à faire,
parce que, là encore, sinon
on se retrouve avec des situations
qui peuvent être vécues
comme des humiliations symboliques,
là non plus
sans faire de manichéisme.
Vous avez vu récemment les annonces
sur les augmentations de salaire
de tel ou tel grand dirigeant
de grande entreprise,
il en a le droit,
c'est son autorité,
mais ça relève plus d'une forme
d'humiliation, d'autoritarisme,
et mettre plus de gouvernance
avec plus de salariés
dans cette gouvernance,
ça me paraît un enjeu
majeur pour demain.
-Merci. Il nous reste,
quasiment le temps est complètement
écoulé. J'ai peut-être quelques
minutes, très brèves d'ailleurs,
pour vous présenter
une bibliographie.
Alors,
un livre de Daniel Susskind :
Cette utopie de la fin
du travail inspire.
On verra ici
comment l'évolution,
notamment numérique reconfigure
le monde du travail.
Alors, Nicolas Mayer-Rossignol,
vous avez publié
avec Guillaume Bachelay :
Quelle gauche
et quelle crise ? En deux mots.
On peut se poser la question.
-Je dois à l'honnêteté de dire
que ce livre a été publié en 2010,
donc avec un peu d'autodérision,
la gauche était déjà en crise.
-Ca a changé aujourd'hui ?
-En 2010, elle était en crise
et en 2012, elle a gagné.
En 2022-2023, la gauche est toujours
en crise. En 2027, on verra.
-C'est un signe de bonne santé, ça ?
-Vous savez ce que c'est,
je vais vous répondre
par le mot de Churchill :
"Le vrai succès est
d'aller d'échec en échec
"avec toujours
le même enthousiasme."
-Merci.
Jean-Claude Mailly,
vous avez publié
un livre qui s'appelle :
Vous continuez à chuchoter
à l'oreille d'Emmanuel Macron ?
-Ah non, pas du tout.
Je n'ai plus de contacts avec lui
depuis que je suis parti.
-Vous chuchotez à l'oreille
des responsables de Force Ouvrière ?
-Je suis parti, ils se débrouillent.
S'ils ont besoin, ils m'appellent,
mais c'est pas moi... Excusez-moi,
je vais être brutal,
je veux pas être le vieux con
qui donne ses conseils.
-OK. On a bien compris.
Clara Gaymard,
vous avez publié
avec Bérénice Bringsted :
Franchement,
de quels changements, vous voulez...
-C'était un livre,
donc c'est ma fille,
mais l'idée, c'était
d'évoquer le sujet du travail,
le sujet du rapport
à la consommation,
tous les grands thèmes
qui ont porté Mai-68,
et sur lesquels les jeunes,
la jeune génération
et notamment les millenials
recontestent tout.
Ils nous jugent
très, très sévèrement.
Donc c'était
un dialogue pour montrer
qu'en fait, on s'aime
beaucoup entre générations,
mais on ne se comprend pas,
on ne parle pas la même langue.
Tout le sujet qu'on a aujourd'hui
sur la valeur travail,
sur les retraites, sur la façon
d'appréhender notre vie en société,
vient du fait
que la génération montante pense
que nous nous sommes trompés.
C'est l'objet de ce livre.
-Merci. Je voudrais rappeler,
j'ai cité l'étude
de l'Institut Montaigne
sur les Français et le travail.
Cette étude a été faite
par l'économiste Bertrand Martinot.
Est-ce qu'Alain Villemeur,
vous avez un livre
à suggérer ?
-Non. Enfin, bon, nous,
on a publié avec Jean-Hervé Lorenzi
un livre il y a un an
chez Odile Jacob, qui s'appelle :
Derrière, c'est l'idée qu'il faut
faire face à la fois
à la transition démographique,
à la transition numérique
et à la transition écologique,
dont on a peu parlé,
mais qui est un défi considérable.
Et concilier les trois,
les trois défis,
c'est l'enjeu à notre avis
de ces 10 prochaines années.
-Il me reste à vous remercier,
madame,
merci, messieurs,
d'avoir participé à l'émission.
Evidemment,
elle n'est pas exhaustive
sur la question du travail,
on aura l'occasion d'en reparler.
Merci à l'équipe de LCP
qui a permis
la réalisation de cette émission.
Avant de nous quitter,
je voudrais vous laisser
avec ce clin d'oeil
de Simone de Beauvoir.
"C'est par le travail
que la femme a en grande partie
"franchi la distance
qui la séparait du mâle.
"C'est le travail qui peut seul
lui garantir une liberté concrète."
Vous êtes d'accord,
Clara Gaymard ?
-Ah oui !
-OK.
-Enfin, il n'y a pas
que le travail.
SOUS-TITRAGE : RED BEE MEDIA